dai ma organizziamo qualcosa non ci
vediamo mai adesso un caffè No guarda
Tesoro giusto 40 secondi poi devo
scappare che c'è una partita di Padel
lunedì no lunedì non ci sono perché
prima pilates poi pole dance e poi col
dentista martedì invece viene a trovarmi
mia cugina dall'Australia E quindi
volevo stare un po' con lei se portarla
in giro Mercoledì invece Ma sai che
forse mercoledì sono libera No neanche
mercoledì tesoro Ma sai perché Perché
devo portare Fuffi dal veterinario ogni
volta che vado perdo almeno 4 ore 1:00
giovedì e una delle più incasinate
perché io ho box pilates yoga e poi la
sera cinema con due mia amica Venerdì mo
venerdì è perfetto Anche perché Marco è
una cena di lavoro quindi sono sola
soletta No tesoro scusa mi manca venerdì
ho invitato mia mamma le avevo promesso
una serata a mamma e figlia sabato no
perché al mattino devo portare la
macchina dal meccanico e poi andiamo a
una cena con gli amici di Marco ti
inviterei anche tesoro ma ti annoieresti
no domenica no tutte le prime domeniche
del mese faccio una gita fuori porta a
quella famiglia di Marco guarda ehm Mi
dispiace Uffa però cioè tu scrivimi tu
scrivimi un buchetto non riesco a
trovare